thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a grungy
wild ride with Stevo we've got Gavin
Rossdale lead singer of bush and man is
this guy a rock star not the kind of
rock star you would imagine very unusual
rock star and a candid one too this guy
just opens up about everything even drug
addiction I'm telling you it gets very
juicy so let's get into it so you're
ready to go hell yeah all right I'm very
ready here we go I'm excited
ladies and gentlemen Gavin Rossdale
hey how are you come on man doing great
thank you for joining us I'm happy to
join you and Wendy anytime in our rapey
van
I like the shoes a little rapey from the
outside but full full high-tech on the
inside so it's cool yeah yeah and
generally the consensus is it looks a
lot bigger on camera
get in here and it's it's pretty tight
right right right but the convenience of
bringing it to the guest it's so amazing
thank you so much we got ripped off the
air one afterwards if you like yeah yeah
you know anybody want a 25 Buck coffee
with a shot of gold they have the
smoothie in there for 25 bucks really
yeah yeah with a shot of ozone for like
a hundred dollars that's hilarious I did
take a girl on a date there once and she
managed to forget the smoothie that
really was like they were like you know
just I don't care whatever together you
know there'll be 75 bucks I was like we
got a smoothie right there's nothing
else coming no no that's it it's the
Green Goddess of Life smoothie so
hilarious
um I actually can't go get ripped off at
arawan because I gotta get down to San
Diego where I'm commentating the cage
Warriors MMA fights wow oh that's today
I forgot about that yeah I love that
that's sick are you a fan of the
fighting UFC see Jared I love it I do I
like wait yeah I love it and I'm like I
wince when it starts getting really
bloody lower down the card when people
are sort of less good and just getting
the shake it out of them you know the
face is all over the place I find that
license quite hard I don't like when the
girls and maybe you can't say that in
2023 I'm not a big fan of the girls
taking each other's faces off it just
feels especially like in bare knuckle
when the girls do bare knuckle boxing
you're just like oh this feels weird but
I'm traditional like that I'll probably
get it right I'm gonna get hate mail for
that I don't think you will I don't
think you will and um with what we do uh
all the jackass stuff
um you know there's always been you know
oh you should have an all-girls jackass
and and I've always believed Jain ass
Jill
there's something about
testosterone
stupidity and testosterone yeah like the
the the
the role that the the
human men that is to be a provider a
protector be macho and an idiot and an
idiot yeah exactly and all of that
Dynamic makes it funny to see a man fail
and get hurt right but a woman her role
is to be a nurturer uh you know you've
had women on jackass and she got so hurt
that you didn't air it right yeah
they're way back when we had a Stephanie
Hodge and she broke her back oh you just
you didn't air because it wasn't funny
it wasn't cool yeah it was there's
nothing funny or cool about breaking a
woman's back it's funny when danger
Aaron breaks his neck
yeah
it's pretty funny
okay we
um so so we're here
to talk about the new Bush album oh
great thank you yeah
the art of survival which is very UFC in
of itself I use that as an analogy a lot
of the time because I kind of feel that
you know we've had so much success as a
band and we kind of like every band if
you've been around forever you kind of
go in and out of of hotter times you
know leaner times great times but what I
just feel as a band we're so on fire
it's really exciting we've been on these
tours and
just just great you know I mean I just
appreciate all these people coming out
to see us and getting excited about it
and like blows me away you know you
can't take yourself that seriously but
when other people take you seriously
it's kind of cool sure you know yeah
we're definitely seeing uh
is there a Revival it's weird to think
that the 90s
uh is
um
subject for for a Nostalgia but here we
are getting old huh yeah yeah it can't
help us how it goes it's crazy yeah the
funny thing is it's like
um for us you know we never stop trying
we never stop being around and like
certain moments where you get the right
tour the tour goes great we make the
right record and uh you have a nice a
lot of hits off of it or you make a
record that's like less hits on it you
know so it's just it's just I think it's
just wild to still be doing it you know
love coming to do this it's just it's a
it's a fruitful time I like it you know
a lot of stuff going on how much is how
much different is touring in the 90s
2000s and 2020s
does it change much or is it same
different attitude well
um I think that you know the beginning
when we began it the audiences were like
nuts and more insane and maybe there's a
sense that a lot of those uh when we
play Big festivals it feels the same I
mean
it's cool it's just people going crazy I
think it's the person's job whether
you're doing stand-up whether you're
doing music you have to be entertaining
and the better you are and the more out
there you are the more they can relax
and just lose themselves and so I
haven't you know could I think that
maybe in the 90s it was a little bit
more chaotic more kind of stage diving
and Stage Invasion stuff like that and
now everyone's like getting you know
sort of worried about covered and
sprayed with the antisepter here put
these pure wipes for you go on stage and
that kind of [__] and what I used to do
I used to have a lot of people come on
stage as the end on the last song which
is really fun and when I did it recently
because we had a stage that was weirdly
there's no barricade which we've never
had no barricade I was like oh well [__]
it might as well have them on stage and
they came on stage and I was waiting for
this like triumphant moment I was like
yeah we're all in it together and look
around and everyone's [__] filming
from on stage I'm like no no you
remember Europe now part of the
performance it's not about you capturing
the moment like you're not there you're
in it you are the performance so that
was a bit so I was like all right I'm
not gonna do that [__] anymore that's
[__] work you know filming too much
yeah it's crazy
did this bush have a a position about
that do you try to prevent people from
filming the shows oh no no no that we
just drew good luck can you imagine Whoa
stop stop stop stop everybody's doing it
but you do get the sense that people
take themselves out of the moment you
know if you're filming you're not really
present you're kind of making sure your
angle's right and all that stuff right
so that I'm not a fan of but oh it'd be
terrible to be sort of trying to shut
down progress in the future could
everyone stop the future you know so I
say just get make it a good angle you
know make sure it's good don't use it if
it sucks if it sucks you know often the
mistakes and when things go wrong is
that makes the best footage anyway you
know people like that stuff you know
right I was on tour
um last year four months on tour and one
time I had I had my Roadie guitar tech
Roadie guitar tech excuse me that's very
90s my guitar take uh was ex-marine
right and
um Ace and one guy came up when in fact
that night where I invited him on stage
one guy came to sing grab the microphone
and before he could get to the mic the
guy drop kicked him from the side like I
don't know why he was so upset like he
might sing I was like it's okay it's
just a [__] microphone but he dropped
kicked him made the press and my mom
called me I was like oh my God you know
it's like no one cares about this show
or anything like that but the guy
getting dropkick that was rad that was
my mum was like that's world news
was uh the was it negative press like uh
you know a fan was badly assaulted kind
of the terrible thing happened
just like that we have Kung Fu techs
which is kind of cool
nice nice
um so I I saw something
um you were talking about Joe Rogan and
Spotify and and uh it sounded like you
were heaping Praise on Joe Rogan because
he's fantastic
um but you felt a little bit uh
conflicted about well there's a sense of
irony you know like if you Spotify is
the new MTV in that we all make records
and then you try and put them on there
and you hope like that and they hope
that you get streams and all that stuff
and in the same way that you know back
in the day in the 90s you'd spend like
500 000
it sounds so dumb but you would on
videos to try and get on on TRL and try
and make it and be like you know please
put us on and so there's this sort of a
loose irony that that um
Spotify is paying people a lot of money
to join them and to to bring them over
to have the podcasts and and yet the the
musicians just have to keep giving them
just giving the product it's not like
you know what I mean so and obviously
there's a little discrepancy people you
know you have to make a lot of streams
to get paid so for young people in music
it's quite must be quite hard to make a
good living
um from streaming it's really really not
easy right so it's just that I mean
yeah it's just that it's like I don't
really care about it you know again it's
like that progress thing you just sort
of for me my job is to make songs that
are good perform them really well and
try and make people like us that's it I
don't do I concern myself with like
Spotify sort of approach to getting
podcasts versus how they get better I
think I don't care I don't care really
but it's ironic so I mean there's a
sense of irony in there it's built off
of the musicians building that platform
that's how they get the money in there
and then they take their money they give
a bit back to the mostly to the labels a
little bit gets the artist and then tons
of money goes to uh signing people you
know right not musicians right that's
interesting because of what what I would
have thought you you'd be saying about
Spotify
but artists were upset that um they
would weren't receiving money for all
the streams it but you're actually
saying you just want to be played on
there yeah well of course we do I mean
you want to be you want to be out there
I use this all about at the end of the
day artists ever since the recording
industry began I've been screwed over
and over since the beginning of time you
know what I mean and certain people get
Superstar deals you talk about when you
talk about average uh people making
music and getting signed to labels
specifically major labels you know it's
usually very much in the favor of the
labels of course and so there's always
that sense of us against them if you're
a lifelong artist like me you know
versus labels and I know how they all
the stuff they do to artists and free
goods and just the [__] that they do
to squeeze money out of them has Bush uh
switched labels
yeah we we yeah over the years we were
within scope for a long time uh with all
the team over there and then I did a
little time no I mean with BMG a while
so now we have the same label for a
while if you're just consistent enough
and they're they're they're pretty good
label they're very good label we've had
some nice we're on a hit record I have a
hit record right now I thought that's
why you called me yeah
for sure
um yeah
I I wonder too if um
are there uh
any moves ever to make your own label is
that something you're interested in I
did do that um back in the day
um I signed a band called Souls I was so
I did try that and I we had to buy them
off of Warner Brothers and get them on
through Interscope and I was trying to I
was trying to say what's the best deal
we can give and what's the fairest deal
what's the coolest thing we can do for
them and all the execs are like what the
[__] is wrong with this guy yeah he's
not playing the game but unfortunately
there's a great band they sound like
Jesus Lizard fronted by Bjork and they
were incredible they were incredible and
then they we took them on tour with the
Jesus Lizard for like four months and
then they decided to break up they were
going to break up and I found them I was
like don't break up let me take you on
tour you guys are incredible but it
didn't it doesn't work out for them
timing and
ah timing is everything and I know that
probably better than anybody because
just about a half an hour before my lady
and I get into bed that's the time I
like to chew up a Bluetooth tablet and
maybe even two and I'll tell you that
makes getting into bed with my lady a
whole lot of fun why because Bluetooth
tablets have the same active ingredient
as both Viagra and Cialis but they only
cost a fraction of the price and man if
you've ever wondered if this is a lot of
fun what I'm talking about I can assure
you it is and I can also assure you that
as a listener of the Wild Ride podcast
you can get an entire month's supply of
Bluetooth tablets absolutely for free
all you pay is five bucks for shipping
yeah dude you just go to bluetooth.com
you use the promo code Stevo you consult
with the medical provider online to take
care of the prescription and boom
an entire month's Supply is on its way
to you and all you pay is five bucks for
shipping and when it gets to you
I can assure you you're gonna have a
really good time so one more time go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code Stevo
for an entire month's Supply absolutely
for free just pay five bucks for
shipping now let's get back to it but no
uh I'm doing other things I have a
clothing label I'm doing that sea of
sound and I finally I've got my Shopify
account and I release a new t-shirt
yesterday so it's beginning I was at my
kids assembly for his graduation it's
going to sing all the money it's not a
lot it's like 780 I made this morning
but it was so cool and I was like see
you on my Shopify where can they can
what's the website sea of sound dot
design
now you say that you you do it through
Shopify does that mean that you're doing
your own fulfillment so you have a
fulfillment center I have a manufacturer
yeah that I mean the sort of a partner
that I'm with yeah is that what you mean
fulfillment fulfillment meaning uh when
somebody orders the shirt yes hacked
into the the Box yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's the warehouse they have that yeah
where I get it done yeah and they have a
whole little yeah so an order comes in
they get the T-shirt or they get the
whatever the sweatshirt and uh you do it
just we just launched it a little while
ago this is like the second drop it's
too expensive to do the whole thing
traditionally so I've been doing it like
these small drops uh so that it can just
it's not like throwing money away and
and what is uh your mechanism for for
promoting that well so far lacking
lacking could do better uh so I do it on
my Instagram and I have sea of sound
um but I just sorry on my sea of sound
site and on my Gavin Rossdale site and
that's about it and so I just got a
company in who marketing apparently told
me that we got everything wrong with uh
meta data and how to speak and how to
get to Google to Google analytics that's
that's I'm getting schooled in that
stuff and having to redo everything
including names tagging all that sort of
stuff that was like we're artists we
want to write what we want you know
right it's a bare skin t-shirt it's not
enough they go no not enough
no I don't know I'm just saying that
what I want to say something as I would
say they keep saying don't forget to put
in the keywords you know so does bush
own the rights to like Bush merch yeah
so you guys yeah yeah yeah do some
record labels own the name sometimes and
that's how they get money or is it all
part of the news this one 360 deals have
that but we we don't do 360 deals so we
yeah we do it ourselves and we just we
had a great run this last tour I really
like it you know I like I like cool
stuff and I think that clothes are real
good way of making self feel you know
powerful and take on the day and I think
it's really important quality you know
it's not vanity it's just sort of armor
and so I love getting into I've always
done our merch and you do the merch
design it that's cool it's really basic
as in how many ways can you write Bush
you know I mean this way that way but I
just do yeah it's cool I have fun doing
it and
uh I love it and what I also really like
which are Nick from Sepultura is
um all our crew have they get whatever
merch they want so any Festival yeah
anything like that there's always like
15 20 people cool looking like tatted up
dudes all in the bush thing and it just
feels like a like a tribe like an army
it's cool and I uh yeah I like that so
it also helps you when you so many
people on stage and they're like this
guitar is too loud when I look you know
look for someone in a bush shirt I like
that so it's helpful do you guys travel
on tour bus do you guys take planes or
do you guys tour bus always tour bus
yeah planes suck I mean look I'm not
again so you know maybe after this
podcast I'm going to get to the private
jets that I want yeah so I'm expecting
that's why I agree to look to the
numbers here 1.6 million I figured you
know what could be closer to a private
jet and uh but otherwise up until then
it's all Southwest can you know so I
don't really like flying
um buses are the best
thank you Lord for tour buses how many
buses do you guys
uh Caravan with one two one three three
tour buses
and
to a truck probably for the merch yeah
and for the gear of course you tell us
boring stuff like that yeah the old
guitars yeah uh so yeah we're kind of a
lean mean machine
so
you uh
uh are
just an incredibly youthful shape right
I mean like how do you stay so damn
healthy
um
I love I like to sweat and I like that
feeling that you get I just did a
workout this morning I work out a lot in
a sweatsuit you know I do everything in
a sweatsuit like the the cut weight
stuff
um and I'm really active on stage and I
just think that that
um I've always been I'm like an art jock
you know what I mean so my whole life I
grew up playing soccer really was pretty
good at soccer and uh and I love tennis
and healthy things like that then I love
kind of staying up and having fun like
with with art projects so I kind of do
it both I'm not like um
yeah so I've always I think it just
makes you feel better right I mean just
to be fitter and stuff like that just
feel good yeah what's your diet like
indulgent in a really indulgent and just
sort of balanced I mean just
pretty indulgent as in that I just live
you know I'm like fully aware that if I
eat shitty for five days straight you
know I'm gonna have you know I'm gonna
be like regretting it so it seems like
shitty I eat good be cleaner I like to
cook that helps because I cook quite
clean so how can British people have a
better way of saying [__] than Americans
like what should I like indulgent I'm
like what's indulge in me you know like
it means I go for it you know what I
mean I cook in butter and and uh I'm
very basic you know it's just try and
get keep eat organically I went through
a whole I dated a vegan I know that you
were I know that you're a pescatarian
now right now so I did you know a lot of
I I you know with a lot of I was well
into that whole vegan lifestyle but I
found it quite difficult for how to
sustain me I didn't feel that healthy
off of it but I but I'm very you know um
you know I care about sort of how
animals are treated rear raised uh
dispatched all that stuff I just you
know and I feel sort of horrible at it I
always think that that the vegans not
the militant ones but the kind of
regular vegans and I've a lot of friends
with vegans you know have a the moral
High Ground that I can't really I can't
hang with you know because really we
should try and avoid eating meat right I
think that Above All Else
factory farming is particularly
upsetting it you know so wild don't you
think it's now this time it's such an
incredible time because
we've now seen that Industrial
Revolution was a disaster it used to be
seen because no one ever considered
animals as sentient beings you know so
just sort of seeing as like factually
how can we feed all these people and
um and so what happens the industrial
revolution has destroyed everything he's
destroying everything the rainforest
still I was reading this morning you're
like
what's that sweets
with 30 million trees in six years it's
just some insane amounts of it's in the
Guardian newspaper today I was reading
it like oh my God so it really is about
responsible the responsibility of of
farming and um it's a difficult one you
know now you get all this thing about
how uh kale and spinach have oxalates
and you know you know a sort of Defense
chemicals that are really not good for
us and some people get sort of they're
all bloated and feel shitty it's like
that kale salad isn't good for you so
he's like what do you eat what are you
many I was like used to be like my
favorite vegetable I'd be like I'm gonna
have that all the time and stuff like
that and now you're finding out that
it's it's um maybe these things aren't
so good to eat CMOS I did hear the
spinach contributes to kidney stones
yeah right and I did that crazy
um DNA thing where you find out what's
going to happen to you the rest of your
life the word yeah we you can find out
if you're going to get Alzheimer's or
anything yeah whatever any single ale
mode you don't want to do it because
they find out they're going to say no
I'm not going to you know I have the
Alzheimer's Gene either so I don't have
the Alzheimer's Gene and I don't have
the diabetic Gene but I do have the gene
for high kidney failure I was like whoa
what's up with that my kidneys are fine
um but again the guys the doctor's like
well yeah but it could happen anytime so
I'm in the high 85 percentile for like
terrible kidney stuff so I used to love
spinach so since I found out about
spinach because I've just read that I
was like am I not allowed to eat spinach
now right so salt Salt's a big one for
the kidneys right oh you didn't ready I
just said it I'm sorry now I know it's
gonna be there Salt's great right so
yeah it's red and that table saw but you
can do other types of salt that's yeah
lava rock salt or Himalayan salt okay I
wonder so where do you go to get this
DNA test oh just to this there's this Dr
Stanford this guy in fact my record
project well guy uh done a couple of
records with Tyler Bates do you know
Tyler Bates these are the most amazing
uh composer film composer and songwriter
I've done like loads of songs with him
um three songs on this record I wrote
with him and uh anyway he he turned me
on to to this doctor and I was like some
people wanna don't wanna do that and
want to find out you want to live in
ignorance and I just go no I want to
like I want to head this off because I
could have been it could have been
really bad I had a friend of mine who's
a sister uh found out she had the
Alzheimer's Gene it's just so that she's
like oh my God luckily I told his doctor
that he said well so do I so send her
into me so she went in to see him and he
kind of educated it doesn't you know
even in the high percentile doesn't mean
that you're gonna actually get it just
means you have a high propensity I don't
have the gene in my Grandpa Grandpa died
of early on said Alzheimer's but just
because I don't have the gene doesn't
mean I can't get it either
right there's like a nine percent chance
that I can versus if I did have the gene
I'd have like an 80 chance or whatever
it was so they lost two bits of info I
didn't like yeah
my buddy Tony Hawk told me about that
test for the Alzheimer's Gene and that
if you have the Alzheimer's Gene you're
at a considerably higher risk for
developing the CTE from uh concussions
really yeah and um I remember chewing on
that you know and and thinking I said do
I want to get this test but like what
you know you can't unhit your head
definitely that definitely that's
difficult to want to hit your head yeah
you can stop hitting your head right
that's a good one yeah Tony said that he
didn't have the Alzheimer's Gene but
then I called him back while later and
said hey Tony what was your plan if you
did have the Alzheimer's jeans no I
didn't I don't know you know so it does
become a a consideration do you want
uh the answer to a question that you
can't fix that you can't yeah like but
you can think there's if God is omnipson
can he make himself a breakfast that's
too big to eat isn't that kind of thing
wow that was deep it caught me off guard
and I don't even know what to do with it
but you know what I've lived in my house
for almost an entire decade and I'm just
thinking about how to celebrate that you
know how I celebrated moving in I got
myself Squatty Potty for every single
toilet in the house and for the last
almost 10 years I've taken every single
dump with my feet perched on that
Squatty Potty now if you don't know
about this then this is a big time
important because by raising your feet
when you take a dump you simulate the
position of crouching which is how our
bodies were actually intended to take a
dump we weren't supposed to sit on
something supposed to crouch in the
woods and our intestines and our whole
body is lined up like that so that you
really have to be crouching if you want
to take a perfect healthy and complete
dump that's why my squatty potty's so
crucial and you can get 20 off your
Squatty Potty if you go to
squattypotty.com
Stevo once again that's that's squatty
potty.com slash Stevo and I can't tell
you how important this is because by not
pooping in the right position you are
taking on health risks okay and I want
you to be healthy and I want you to take
full complete dumps so go to
squattypotty.com Stevo for twenty
percent off your order now let's get
back to it
I just saw somewhere that they're
starting to call Alzheimer's uh type 3
diabetes and it it can help if you
reduce your sugar intake you're you're I
think it's something to say if you would
you would tailor your life so that you'd
know that literally you just it maybe
improves your focus and and being
healthy and inspires you to to live a
cleaner life you know
um I don't know yeah sugar is gnarly man
said that like
nicotine is bad for you to inhale but
it's good for your brain to protect you
from Alzheimer's and Parkinson's I don't
think nicotine is broken it's it's all
of the stuff that comes with the tobacco
the tar the you know yeah so the idea is
right is that you basically start
smoking at 65 you start like just fresh
you go to Paris it protects you yeah I
mean there's somebody made a point that
you see old people smoking cigarettes
all the time you know it's like old
people
everywhere yeah wherever wherever but
you never see like really old super
obese people yeah
true that your waistline is your
lifeline isn't it I read that the bigger
your waistline the shorter your lifespan
the shorter your waistband the longer
your lifespan hmm wow yeah it's crazy
yeah all right I want to switch gears
the first song you ever wrote was
glycerine
will come down ah okay come down
glycerinar of a few weeks later because
I just thought then I got on a roll then
I sort of like okay okay it's not like
that you know I could be a busker but
how are you records how are you where
you're not like when you do that in your
first hits your first thing you wrote as
a hit were you worried about being a
one-hit wonder or when you're on a roll
like that you don't even think about
that point I was like in living my life
like living in an apartment with five
people a painting job painting houses
and just thinking just let me make a
[__] record already like this is
embarrassing I told everyone I'm a
singer and I can't even get arrested so
my only my my threshold was really low
we used to go out to nightclubs clubs
and go out and be like you know look at
that guy he's got a he's got a deal [__]
he's got a deal how do you get a deal
you know then you'd see someone from a
label be like oh my God there's [__]
face from like you know from from from
record labels just play you could change
my life please change my life but they
didn't change my life you know and um so
I got to make 16 Stone
and um which is that record come down is
on and then after that the um the story
is that we lost the distribution so I
did that record and completed it it's
come down glycerin everything's in all
the all the that that record and uh they
took it to the label uh that we were
Hollywood Records at the time and they
threw the record physically at the guy
from my small independent label and said
not only are there no singles on this
record there's no album tracks and we
got dropped from Hollywood Records which
is cut from Disney which is kind of a
slap in the face but a welcome slap in
the face because I didn't want to be in
the first place I was like you know I
want to be cool I was like we're on
Disney records on Hollywood Records this
isn't so cool and they chucked us off
because Frank Wells who signed us had
got killed in a helicopter crash and
that's what's weird about life is that
you learn so much I went back to work I
painted 12 dentist offices in the West
End of London and Magnolia actually not
the similar to that color Magnolia like
it's like a peachy it's like white that
you don't have to wash for 10 years it's
very cheap uh dentist office color and I
did those song uh those apart um there's
big offices the 10 11 of them I think
and in the middle of that and I was like
well I made the record so I didn't have
any wasn't a hit at all and then they
said to me oh
k-rock's playing your record You're
Everything Zen is on K-Rock you got to
come back to America we we're gonna you
got to meet this company you've got to
meet Ted field Jimmy Ivey and I was like
what's K-Rock and I thought I was signed
I was like so dumb and confused and I
came to America and I understand stay
here we can see it the Hilton Hotel
first hotel I've ever got paid to stay
in and Universal musician yeah Universal
I made people I knew come out see me I'm
like I'm at the hotel I gotta run paper
for my music you gotta come see it it's
like a room at the Hilton but it's the
greatest thing ever and so that's how
that began and so Everything Zen was in
here then little things was a hit then
come down was a hit then Glycerine was
here so I was like I was already when
calm down came out I'd already had three
so I was about to be a four hit wonder
the uh guy who kicked you off the
Hollywood Records
sorry sack of [__] well in a Buddhist
way I'm grateful right because I then
went to Ted field took me to uh in scope
and then I had the muscle of Interscope
and had I gone to to Hollywood Records
out of who knows I mean I may not have
made it to this podcast right it may
have just been an air one wishing I
could afford the coffees and just
getting like you know instead it's just
I mean life is all about these like
weird influent confluences of things
right like I don't believe in much but I
believe in the energy Universe Works in
a weird way to bring people together and
you get that synchronicity that's what I
you know I'm you know the whole you know
Karma and God and all those things
people they're not so much for me I'm
sort of like on Earth on my feet on the
ground I feel responsible for what I
should do in my actions you know and uh
but I do believe that uh you find
yourself where you should be at all
times no matter how horrible those times
are I do believe that that's your
destiny of where you should be so the
fact I got dropped by a label I didn't
want to be on was was perfect it was a
bit harsh because I was like I told
everyone that I was going to be
successful and then there I was painting
but come and see me at work you know
covered in pain at the pub you know yeah
it's gonna be great I'm gonna be massive
yeah but hindsides 2020 so were you
really feeling that way when you did get
dropped or were you like ah if I get
something else will come up better
enjoys to be true truthful I was so used
to failing and so I used to know that I
was like oh okay how we're going to deal
with this no life wasn't about you know
when you're young and
as dumb as that and just like full of
energy you just a no just means that
we've got to go around it okay I've got
to go around it I didn't stop I got no
from everyone I've assigned to a label
in the valley
when I was in London so I got told no
like every single day worse than no
nothing you know I go get demo time
we're gonna do three songs and you just
wait and then they wouldn't tell you
anything they wouldn't say this is why
this is what is done wrong this wouldn't
say anything it's getting ghosted that's
the beginning of ghosting my first
ghosting yeah I'm pretty sure ghosting's
always been a thing you know but it's so
brutal you know especially now I think
of it being you know early 20s you could
just benefit from some someone at the
label saying hey this is these are the
three things reasons why we didn't sign
you go work on those things but they
literally had no belief in me whatsoever
I didn't feel the need to even tell me
the simplest of things you know what was
your dad's definition of no
a request for further information
I love that it's so good yeah
I'm surprised you guys never I mean from
London and Steve's from London I know I
feel bad but we've yeah we should we uh
not there in a couple weeks oh yeah
oh wow how's that going it's uh it's
it's it's it's been spectacular it's
going spectacularly well and I'm taping
the my next special in London at the
Hackney Empire when what date uh this is
gonna be on July 14th and I'm itching to
uh add a show on the 13th so I can have
three shows to to tape yeah so um that's
also how do you like I was watching
um I love stand-ups I watch it all the
time
and I watched Jerry yesterday I want to
watch the clean one of Jerry Seinfeld
okay you know and just amazing just
there's that ability because I mean I
love Lewis CK obviously you know Bill
Burr is my total hero of all time
um Jim Jefferies yeah incredible
um [__] yeah
he's amazing yeah so I love it but I was
intrigued about it like so you have to
do so much work to get that amount of
material together and then does that
sort of when you're up there must be
kind of
I mean I go up on stage and I but I I
talk for a bit and I some nights I'm
really I'm I'm on it sometimes I'm just
loose and you know you know say stupid
stuff like you know I just hate it when
people say songs are the babies it's so
dumb they're not songs they're not
babies they're songs you know right so
you have these thoughts but as a
stand-up comedian you have to have but
other nights I'll be like I can't
remember what they're saying he's
playing another song but for you as a
standard comedian you got to be like
that flow that easy delivery you know
difficult audiences I mean how do you
deal with heckless for example oh God
I'm terrible with that loose man I'm
notoriously terrible with hecklers
because you've got to get your [__]
going on there You Gotta Be You know
yeah Jimmy Carr oh my God now Jimmy Carr
he's my favorite he is insane you know
what's really insane the way that humans
have been destroying the world with
plastic and that is why I I am so loyal
to liquid death because it comes in
infinitely recyclable aluminum cans and
they look like beers but it's just water
unless you get the Liquid death tea the
new teas man so awesome armless Palmer
grim leafer and rest in Peach I mean
come on and if you get the Iced Teas on
Amazon free shipping as well as a bunch
of retailers in your in your area yeah
man plus listeners of the Wild Ride
podcast they get 20 off their first
purchase of apparel at liquiddeath.com
if you go to liquiddeath.com
Stevo that's
liquiddeath.com
Stevo 20 off the apparel check it out
this stuff is epic and man drinking
water is actually really good for you
too I uh been drinking a lot more water
been stretching in the mornings I'm
doing everything right I feel good and I
feel really good about liquid death so
go to liquiddeath.com Stevo get that
apparel drink the water drink the tea
feel good about yourself and save the
world now let's get back to it I I just
uh is that your mom yeah
come back I just feel that that heckling
is
vandalism to the show of course it is
it's just it's you know and um
the idea that all of these people have
come out they've spent their hard-earned
money they here they are to enjoy the
show and then
you got somebody a couple people are
gonna vandalize it for them it's just so
disrespectful to me and um that's what
he say to them
it varies on night tonight but uh
usually it's shut the [__] up and stop
being a [__] [__]
it's very nuanced
do musicians what's a Heckler for you
somebody holding up a [__] son I mean
like I mean you kind of want people
screaming at it yeah like you know no
no there's no I mean the only heckling
the light well we have a different
version of it that's why I go along you
got 15 000 people but why do we always
again there's one guy yawning at the
front I'm like God
someone's not enjoying it right it's so
stupid because you've got like 14 999
people are losing their minds you got
one [__] in the front who's like
wishing the the next band comes on you
like we're all friends and we're good
they're not on stage right now let it go
you know and so that I always find of um
I had it the other day going in the
crowd I love going in the crowd I love
that people just don't expect it and
I've every show I say I'm not going to
do it I've been doing it forever it's
[__] don't make it a [__] in your
life every night boom let's go out it's
[__] great and to go out and the
other night there's like you say go out
in the crowd do you mean like back of
the Arena go into the crowd
surfing well yeah I can jump off the
stage go through the crowd go to the
side go around go up the rafters all way
I love that I mean how do people not
just
because they're just losing their [__]
they're having so much they love it they
know because they because it's like for
that moment I am
part of their wildest fantasy of the
night you know what I mean somebody's
trying to hit you in the Nets or
something
I do get grabbed and a couple times
grabbed a lot so I'm like not now this
is not you know what I mean I'm sweating
it's not a fair representation of who I
am
and it's cold yeah someone will always
come away with a shoe
right yeah but so I like going to do
that and the other night there was
someone who was like you know because we
we played with um
you know we were out with Alice in
Chains and so maybe they're not maybe
want to see Alice in Chains more than
they want to see Bush you know but I
just love going the crown a [__]
scene right like that and this is like
because you just break people's
uh you know
Frosty because when they're like and
they get into it mostly 99 of people
just are just so excited and trying to
get me and doing pictures and doing all
that and grabbing and pulling and and
it's chaos but it's not aggressive like
it's not Hatebreed or uh you know it's
better it's not like I don't hate those
mosh bits the big circles they're
running in bashing each other real
hardcore uh bands getting there I just
moves like this it's like the dumbest
why are you gonna come out and like
wrestle with each other what's up with
that psychologically it doesn't make
sense to me but um so and I don't like
people who don't want to be involved in
that getting like beaten up because that
also sucks like right you know I mean
that's that's real vandalism you know
you're watching showing you've got
people smacking into you and there's
always that happens if there's fights
break out and um but but generally I
just love doing it because it just I I
know it's like for you as a performer
but I'm always looking at ways to be as
wild and as brilliant as possible and
dynamic so it's from being from lying
down on the floor
you know on the stage like a dead body
to being at the back of the Arena sort
of like that singing with someone and
everything in between because it's your
responsibility to be as entertaining as
possible from the minute you're on to
the minute you're off or else what
you're doing that's right that's your
job yeah so I just try and be as dynamic
as possible and jumping off the stage
and going into the crowd is just always
a sure when it just the whole atmosphere
the whole place loses their mind because
you just create chaos but I don't it's
not aggressive chaos it's sort of it's
it's it's just celebratory and sort of
tribal it's Tribal and everyone's just
wants a part of that moment and it's
just it's beautiful
my favorite question to ask bands and
musician is when you guys are traveling
International did you have a favorite
place that you smuggle drugs like where
would Bush put their drugs when they go
flying from place to place
oh
um that would be
um I once had an incredible guitar tech
it was very very considerate
um but generally it's just all about
it's well nowadays you sort of like
legal now yeah before before that it was
just all about you know
um inside you know the sort of like the
fake jars of coffee or the peanut you
know that and the peanut butter on top
and it's all the things you would do to
try and uh to to hide
but you know the other good news of
being bad is that there's always people
around that have not really yeah yeah I
mean it's that thing you know going to
Canada and you have to like like get
this weed and be like we'll see ya let
go of it you're going to Canada and
somebody like hey I'll get some weed
like it's like okay
Vinnie's favorite place to put drugs
I knew it was coming yeah
oh you're familiar with the prison plan
okay the swallow just insert yeah yeah
when he before he went to jail he didn't
go to jail for it yeah I didn't go to
jail for it I went to I was going to
jail and I had a really bad heroin habit
at the time oh so when I turned myself
again
when I turned myself in I put a lot of
stuff up my butt
it's really like but did you like I put
a lot because would you be super
considerate like okay so I'm gonna be
here for what how long are you inside
like six months oh [__] yeah but I I
pretty fun do you think six months up
there no no no no I went through all my
[__] really soon wow but like I I had
enough to last me like a week or two you
know but I knew I was eventually gonna
be sick so I just I need to get more
inside no no not really I use a cold
turkey inside uh pretty much I I like
tried to get on the methadone program
there but it was like the waiting list
and trying to talk to a doctors and
saying really yeah I was addicted to
Xanax oh yeah I brought a lot of Xanax
up there for four years or something
like that when I was just working a lot
uh internationally and I was traveling
and I was like oh look if I take this
I'm gonna go to sleep for eight hours
and I got into this habit and then
suddenly before I knew it was in like
three four years I just couldn't even
think of sleeping without uh Xanax and
um
so I then decided I should stop and I so
I just stopped and I did two weeks where
every night I was like it's like I'd
been in a shower and then I got into bed
you know like as or as wet as I could be
in a lying bed and I just sweats for two
weeks and people told me afterwards was
super dangerous yeah
the most dangerous stop dead yeah oh
stop you know you get dizzy when you
quit Xanax or is it just what was the
withdrawals lying awake at night like oh
[__] but I just I knew that my I really
kind of crossed the line of my fun uh
times out you know weed and sort of fun
drugs but you know smack where I grew up
so this this you know what I mean
there's like there's party side and
there's no to you you know what I mean
there's a whole difference
because you know I was always so
ambitious it was like I couldn't
everyone all of my friends who did
heroin just that's what they did yeah
and I was I wanted to be in a fans that
wanted to be stoned and in a band you
know or do the band thing and then be
wasted at the end of it so I was always
had this focus and uh but it was pretty
scary that um that I just was like wow
what have you done to your body that for
two weeks straight up 14 days no not
much sleep and just pure sweating and
you know that was down to 161 which is
small for me you know because I'm like
heavier than that 85 or 190. so that was
pretty hardcore uh and of course they
any doctor give them to you so there was
no need to smoke all those the things
that were worse for me my whole life I
was just getting them from regular
doctors what years were how old were you
in that time that was about three weeks
ago
[Laughter]
time in my life you've been able to not
do Xanax you know I had a most amazing
moment um on and I I it's a willful name
drop because it's fun for the program
but I had an incredible moment uh
Mastodon is one of my favorite bands
okay I love that band and we were
playing
um rock M ring last year and there's
there's fever 333 Deftones uh Bush
Mastodon we're all on the same stage
um actually at the same time because I
was the day after uh Mastodon but I went
to watch them because I was a huge fan
of it and Brent so whatever and I didn't
know they're so heavy that I didn't know
if they'd like I don't know you know
somebody see Heavy bands you're like are
they going to be friendly are they going
to be like what's it going to be like
super friendly we had a friends we had a
mutual friend we'd done
um uh Ras Linux done a record with him
so I was always like oh the folklore of
Mastodon and they were super friendly
and I went over to them and um we took
pictures of them and I just met Brent
really quickly and I was like
he's asked me how he's doing I've been
having trouble with my voice and I
wasn't feeling good and I was like when
I'm in Europe [__] it I was gonna say
Xanax and I'm just gonna [__] go back
to mosaics and my little pill bottle
with me and I was like it's gonna this
is I'll stop in a month when I finish
the tour I just gotta get this tour my
voice I was telling myself the reasons
why I should take this Xanax because you
know because the first couple of days
you're super jet lagged and you know
you're playing shows and you feel [__]
and I said to him
I'm doing all right and I rattled this
thing in my pocket and I said but I
think that
I I shouldn't probably do it right I
think I'm going to go back on this train
and he goes he goes don't yeah well how
did you get from meeting someone how did
you get from not taking Xanax to having
them in your pocket oh because because
because I I I'd flown over with them so
the one time I will take them is on a
transatlantic flight I'll pop one just
to sleep at night and then I was like
that's it then you get there and then I
thought so I had him on me and I've had
a few rough days and I was like should I
shouldn't I and I again this whole thing
about this is um uh synchronicity and
you know meeting people I met him and I
said to him
yeah I've seen my voice I don't feel
good in my voice and I don't feel very
healthy and I'm being an idiot but I
really might think I might just spend a
month you know doing shows and eating
Xanax so I can get through this and he
then went on to tell me about that his
journey with it how he's addicted to it
for way longer of course you know way
heavier than me way longer than me on
Xanax and he was telling me about how
actually
um it makes you like everything your
everything goes to everything slows down
to the point of close to death
everything slows down all the organs
everything completely that's what it is
everything slows down the NX does that
yeah he's the benzos that's what they do
so I was like I just hugged him you know
what I mean we just I hugged him and I
was like you just saved me because your
wisdom and insight uh experience just
made me
not do that so I kept the pills
obviously
[Laughter]
great you ever tour with uh Smashing
Pumpkins I've done a few shows with them
and we should tour more uh Billy is uh
is
um is amazing and they have a new record
out and we we did a few shows of them in
Portugal a couple of festivals we fit so
well together but he we we haven't got
yet he just did Jane's Addiction now
he's I think it was the Interpol and uh
you should we should tour together it'd
be such a great complimentary bands they
really work well together so maybe we'll
see
yeah Jane's Addiction man have you ever
tour Sublime in the 90s no but I did so
many shows around you know festivals and
stuff with them and there was two they
they contacted me recently about touring
with Sublime in Rome um a little while
ago because we had the same tour manager
but that never came about yeah how are
they doing do you like them I like them
I'm fascinated with them in the 90s
though right I really
I dug the [__] out of them right right
right
when you have a
a hit like glycerin
and you said that it was uh about a girl
named Susie
I think you said it on the Howard Stern
Show
yeah you had a girlfriend that you wrote
the song about right whatever her name
was I was dying to ask this question but
but well my question might be different
than yours but there is a Susie but I'm
not sure if the song that sounds like
whoever the song was about yeah when
that person finds out that there's a hit
song about them like are they like dude
what the [__] or like give me some money
at least or like what's the protocol
there because I'm sure you weren't
expecting that song to just go ape [__]
it's a true story about some girl where
she's probably like yeah I mean the
thing about it is is that lots of lots
of songs for me
um
they can be sort of Patchwork of people
and what people made you feel in that
situation the idea I'm not very I don't
follow that sort of Springsteen
storyline
faithful to the narrator faithfulness or
I'm like the Ginsburg School of Chaos
and Firework words and Firework ideas
and songs to be as fragmented as we are
in the day as this conversation is you
know that means like I just can't
imagine you know just bashing home one
point one person one situation and so
I'm I'm always I just look for the best
line and it so therefore some songs can
be kind of amount you know kind of
Composites of different situations and
so yeah that was Susie but
um there's also like my first girlfriend
you know just they destroy you you know
yeah girls destroy you you know so it's
like I could just I can just I've got
like a draw full of issues with all the
girls I've ever dated me just what I've
done to me like I know it'll fit yeah
I love that [__] yeah you and me both
well you know love addiction makes for
great songwriting I believe in I believe
in in love and um I just listening to an
amazing lecture uh by Alan de bottom uh
the reasons why you will marry the wrong
person
it's just genius wow that's heavy so
yeah we were operating on the assumption
that glycerin it was about a girl named
Susie maybe not just one girl but but
maybe yeah
all Susie's in general yeah and then we
understand that equestrian is actually
like a some kind of explosive explosive
yeah so we were we wanted to ask it's a
song about Susie just having bomb ass
[__]
well uh no sex is good
uh no let me think about that no because
the crazier they are the better the sex
tends to be yeah the crazy hot Matrix
yeah
[Laughter]
imagine that how big the song would have
been if I told everyone that yeah
that private jet after all
yeah that's that's even way to ask them
yeah man
um man so I'm interested the uh
that's just kind of fifteen thousand
that that that's in an arena so so bush
is an arena Act
an arena act in the 90s has it just been
fifteen thousand no that's not at all no
no no just many times we like we'll go
somewhere and it's five thousand or
three thousand and just so no it's it's
a range of it all
um but we've been on a roll
um since for a couple years couple of
Records since the pandemic uh we brought
out the kingdom we had a record called
The Kingdom um which was did really good
even though it was in in the pandemic um
and then we followed up with the art of
survival and I went super heavy you know
because I think at this point in my
career you expected to sort of not phone
in records but just do records that
don't really matter as much as we did
when you were vital and I just hate that
idea I just think that we get wiser as
we get older we should get better at our
crafts that we do and so
um I just I like to debunk that idea and
trying to write the best songs
um that I've ever done I mean I you know
I'm proud of
you know there's a few turkeys here and
there over the years and a few
approaches to sounds that I think didn't
work but we just always try to make rock
interesting I've been around so long and
and so long when people like rock is
dead it's like yeah it is until he pays
60 000 people in Ohio at incarceration
you know like we're gonna go dude so if
there's a real disconnect it's not part
of the mainstream culture in the way
hip-hop is and pop is you know I wish it
was you know I wish I had that audience
but I it's just going to take a number
of bands making the right records and
there's some young bands making some
great records that I hope give people
the kind of confidence to
fall in love again with rock but also it
is Counter Culture right I mean like I
don't want to be I grew up loving like
Punk and so punk bands were never Arena
bands right no punk bands in a real man
what up where what kind of punk bands
oh well I was lucky enough to sort of
you know like the the original English
punk bands you know from x-ray specs
zillows you know slash
um with a clash Sex Pistols on into
Public Image on into gang of four we
were spoiled you know we are spoiled
with all those all the Legacy so that's
why I don't really
a new pop punk for me is not as fun for
me but I have a
16 year old kid 15 year old kid he loves
it you know loves that sound it's
because it's for him you know I'm always
like do you want to hear the Sex Pistols
who are you listening to
you oh man abortions deadly abortions I
really did enjoy they got abortions yeah
they're they're this great band from
British Columbia wow yeah
uh snfu
um of course Misfits right Sam Hayne
um so this is the American scene you
know what about Black Flag Black Flag
big time
yeah I loved all that I liked the Sex
Pistols too what were you listening to
when you're living in the UK
um I mean which time you know like High
School in high school God I went through
a range man and then I I was at the
beginning of high school I was all about
the Misfits seven seconds uh you know um
then and then I got into like the
straight edge hardcore like all the New
York hardcore bands Gorilla Biscuits
fugazi Minor Threat YouTube today
um and then all of a sudden I just
turned into a pothead and it was all the
Grateful Dead
like Molly Crew was your first time in
London
Twisted Sister yep that was my first
concert with Christian sister at Hammer
Smith Guardian really yeah he was scary
wasn't he D Schneider but
yeah
we didn't I mean I love Tommy I we I
didn't grow up with I know this great
Resurgence with a Motley Crue man
they're great they're big now staring
stadiums yeah incredible it's insane he
deserves it he's a great rock star yeah
yeah uh they're they're out in in uh
Europe right now yeah I follow Tommy so
I see you you know he's it's incredible
I'm so happy for him yeah yeah she got a
a bush tour
like happening is yeah well we I think
we have six weeks off now
um I'm actually going to England next
week
um see my family and stuff and uh um
take my boys and then we're doing we're
doing weekend warrior stuff which is
really what I want to do every summer
for the past well so many Summers I'm
always away and
um
this time we're at home it was playing
every weekend until this Festival was
nice so you just fly fly dates no bus
just all fly dates flying up and then
you Park up you haven't you just plug in
and play for an hour and like you know
against all the other bands you so I
mean solo some people try to blow over
enough stage and just like go about your
business and get on a plane and go to
the next one then come on it's like 3D
work three days a week so yeah so like
Darlington is that one of them yeah I
played that last year yeah it's great
yeah I did
um so I said do we have tour dates to
promote and and uh um yeah yeah there's
loads yeah there's quite a few there's
times and where do we send people to
Bush
official or bush bush on online uh
Instagram's easy the bush or under my
name and that's it or bush official
online
that's all there all that information
they're promoting the album yeah I'm
gonna hold that album up do you have a
preferred way that you'd like people to
stream your album it doesn't matter
entire in this entirety the whole damn
thing yeah that's a good answer yeah
that's good but Spotify
um Apple
did you see that that Meme that's going
around not me but what if you call it a
little clip about a guy in England it's
so English as you've got like English
blood in you um because um he goes do
you want you any food yet he goes what
are the choices she goes yes or [__]
no
that's great that for everyone was when
the stewardess asked the guy if he
wanted headphones and he's like how did
you know my name was phones
he never met this we sat next to each
other and we were having sex within two
hours
I don't know how did that happen what do
you mean you so you sit down what were
we through you're drinking obviously no
you weren't drinking no well okay what
are you some kind of magician we got
along really well um it was gorgeous too
she's really hot and then she started
giving me a [__] under the blanket
you've gone way too quick yeah how do
you get to the [__] that's where you
just went way through the two hours way
too quick it was probably less than two
hours to be honest it was like uh well I
came
now you're going too far go back to the
beginning I get on the flight yeah and
Steve's like Yo dude you're in my seat
so I was like all right [__] sorry I
went and got in my seat and then the
super hot chick shows up this is like
Venezuelan you know and I'm like
so me and her like got along really well
and then it was just one of those silly
things where like we're talking Non-Stop
and just kind of like got into it pretty
quickly and then I was like I was like
oh it's crazy like we're in the air it's
like a pretty smooth flight she's like
we're not in the air yet I'm like yeah
we're 100 in the air and she was like
I'll bet you anything that we're not in
the air and I was like if we're in the
air you got to give me a kiss and she
was like deal and she looked out the
window
and we were in the air and then we
started just hooking up that is look at
that that was the line I was waiting for
as he went for it because it could have
gone either way that line you know yeah
she would right I mean you know yeah you
never know but she was pretty
unbelievable and then we met back up in
London I think she lived in um I don't
even know where the nice part of London
is
Chelsea Knightsbridge yeah yeah Chelsea
and then uh it was unbelievable we I'm
North London to [__] hate Chelsea
South London
were you South London
um
I was North London where's Mike Tyndall
uh yeah I feel like he's out in the
country man okay yeah anyway so yeah all
right dude well we uh again we're
sending people to listen to the new Bush
album sweet thank you art of survival
it's a universal is my most universal
title you know I mean nothing everyone
goes through so much all the time the
challenges of daily Modern Life and so
yeah
and we're very intrigued by the uh the
clothing right I see a sound yeah sea of
sound
dot design yeah that's the website and
then sea of sound online and it's yeah
it's easy to find this shirt a sea of
sound it's not I should have worn my
[__] but I didn't oh we should send you
stuff we'll send you some yeah I'll go
on later today and order some for us for
sure we'll send you some stuff too cool
it's pretty cool you really like it it's
of course it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool yeah it's got this rad thing called
the nutrition facts and so I did this
basically a guide to humanity I took it
from I'm obsessed with food and cooking
eating and all that stuff so I did a
nutrition guide for basically a new
guide to humanity and that's on the back
is nice it's got It's a nice thing to
it's a nice it gives it context it's a
little bit more than just
it is just clothes but it's nicer
clothes with the context and sort of a
sort of a mindset yeah order some for a
bunch of us today that'd be amazing
all right my man dude thank you so much
thank you Gavin appreciate it appreciate
that yeah thank you thank you so much
yeah appreciate that all right did you
fall in love with that guy or what I
mean come on I just think he's great and
I think you're great my beautiful street
team what can I tell you guys I mean
foreign
going to the UK coming up real soon and
um we uh
you know
we get these new skateboards that we
made and it's an image on the board the
graphic is of me falling through the sky
blowing a load everywhere it's a
skyjacking skateboard
and I'm really really wondering if uh
if that's going to be uh popular like
how many people want like a
like a skateboard hanging on their wall
that's a guy just coming everywhere I
mean
we're gonna find out
[Music]